all right so we've been talking about
the later stages of the Civil War and in
the last video we just did a brief
overview of the end of 1863 after the
north has won the Battle of Gettysburg
and Lee has been turned around and sent
back down to Richmond where he will be
encamped for some time
and ulysses s grant not only takes
control of the Mississippi River with
the victory at Vicksburg he also comes
up into Tennessee takes control of the
state of Tennessee and in return Lincoln
makes him General in chief of the Union
armies so now let's move on and talk
about 1864 and Sherman's march to the
sea and the election of 1864 both would
be very important to the United States's
victory alright so let's take a look at
our map again now as we recall Lee is
here in Richmond and Grant who was in
Tennessee now coming over to challenge
Lee at the siege of Richmond so grant
has crossed over from the Western
theater of the war where he's been
pretty much the entire time into the
eastern theater and he's kind of going
for the killing blow now and you'll
remember that thanks to the Anaconda
strategy the Union now has control of
the entire area of the south through a
blockade on this side control of the
Mississippi and now control of Tennessee
so there's just this little area that's
left so now what happens well one of
grant's generals who served under him
and this tennessee campaign is now going
to turn his attentions to a massive
campaign of total war in the south so
this is William Tecumseh Sherman and
Sherman's idea is that he is going to
cut a swath through the south and he is
going to try to destroy the South's
morale
I not only trying to get rid of
foodstuffs and interrupt supply lines
destroy infrastructure burn houses he's
gonna make things so bad on the home
front that the Confederate soldiers who
are fighting up here with Lee are gonna
get upset that their property and their
families are not being protected at home
so he's trying to win a morale victory
by making people in the south really
tired of being at war and also by making
Lee's soldiers want to desert and come
back and defend their home territory so
Sherman turns his troops toward Atlanta
and in September of 1864 Sherman takes
Atlanta now there's a very famous scene
of this in Gone with the Wind where you
see Scarlett O'Hara looking out over you
know the many injured people in the city
of Atlanta that's that's Sherman's doing
but now let's turn our attention away
from the military campaigns for a second
and talk about the politics of 1864 now
in 1864 it's an election year it's been
four years since Lincoln was elected in
November of 1860 and so now Lincoln has
to stand for re-election and this is a
really interesting election for lots of
reasons one is that it's the first
election during wartime since 1812 so in
the election of 1864 soldiers are going
to cast their ballots either by getting
short leaves to go to the ballot box or
by sending in their ballots by mail
another thing that's really interesting
about this is that Lincoln is not at all
sure that he's going to win this
election in fact many in his own party
the Republican Party feel that he's been
considerably too soft on the south that
his plans for reunification are not
nearly punitive enough there are many
who want to replace Lincoln with a more
radical candidate in 1864 that does not
end up happening but one interesting
thing that does end up happening is to
try to increase Lincoln's appeal his run
meet is Andrew Johnson and Johnson was a
slaveholder believe it or not from
Tennessee and the idea was that maybe
Johnson could pick up some of the
Democrats who might necessarily have
voted for McClellan and maybe he could
pick up some of the border states the
same way that we often might choose a
vice president today because they come
from a crucial swing state well this is
going to be important later because
after Lincoln is assassinated Andrew
Johnson will take over as president and
he is quite a different president than
Lincoln might have been under the
circumstances now on the Democratic side
the candidate is George McClellan and
you might remember McClellan because he
was one of the first commanders of the
Union Army and Lincoln sent him down for
failing to really go after the enemy
strongly in the early stages of the war
now the Democratic Party is having some
internal struggles at this point there
are some who think that the war against
the south is very foolish that no one
should be fighting in the north to end
slavery which Lincoln has clearly made a
war goal by this point and so many just
wish to have peace with the south on the
terms of the south which is as a
separate nation with the continuation of
slavery and then there are those
Democrats who would like to continue the
war and the cleland ends up being one of
those obviously being a general it would
have been pretty difficult for him to
say that the war was pointless without
having disappointed so many people who
had fought for him or with him this
election is really crucial because many
in the south are hoping that if someone
other than Lincoln gets elected if the
Democrats are elected that is going to
be their last best hope to try to
achieve their independence from the
Union if Lincoln is replaced by someone
who is pro south who is pro-slavery then
perhaps they'll just end the war and
that will be the end of it so whites in
the south are really holding on to the
idea that Lincoln will be defeated in
1864 and there are a lot of reasons to
think that Lincoln might have been
defeated in this Lincoln himself was not
very sure that he would win this
election
remember that there
has not been a single American president
who has been reelected in more than 30
years the last president to be
re-elected was Andrew Jackson in 1832 so
re-election is a very unusual thing at
this point and McClellan was a very
popular general you know he got popular
because he was very keen to spare the
lives of his soldiers which is quite
different than the approach that ulysses
s grant will end up taking at the end of
the war but there are several things
that go in Lincoln's favor one is the
capture of Atlanta by Sherman in
September and some very good military
victories also in this Eastern theater
of the war
so McClellan who had hoped that the war
was going badly didn't have much on his
side when it actually came to election
day because at that point the war was
going pretty well
remember that Sherman is here in Atlanta
and Sherman is now going to pick up what
is known as his march to the sea when he
cuts a 60 mile wide swath of destruction
through Georgia so things are looking
pretty good for the United States at
this point and the turning point for
Lincoln in this election is really the
votes of the soldiers and they have a
really strong Pro Lincoln mandate one of
Lincoln's campaign slogans is vote as
you shot so Lincoln ends up trouncing
McClellan in the election of 1864 and he
really comes away with a strong mandate
to finish the war finish it with an
unconditional surrender of the south and
the end of slavery and having triumphed
in the election of 1864 Lincoln gets
even more good news from Georgia which
is a telegram from General Sherman from
the city of Savannah saying mr.
president I wish to offer you the city
of Savannah
as a Christmas present so in December
25th 1864 Sherman's march to the sea has
concluded and from there he's going to
start heading north and we'll get to
that in the next video